sufrimiento que le haga a la población
lo van a sufrir ellos aquí
[Música]
87 votos a favor
queda aprobado el proyecto de decreto
que contienen régimen de excepción
[Aplausos]
[Música]
yo les digo vean el país donde antes
habían veinte treinta muertos diarios
Donde antes era común encontrar
cadáveres en el suelo y vean cuántos
homicidios hay ahora día semanas enteros
sin homicidios
[Música]
hay jóvenes que están en las cárceles
que no están sin hacer nada sin haber
cometido un delito Simplemente porque
iban en las calles porque le cayó mal al
policía al soldado se lo llevaron
[Música]
yo siempre le oraba a Dios Señor yo
quiero una casa donde vivir Yo tranquila
que nadie me moleste y él lo ha cumplido
el señor
[Música]